it is smoking which it did warn us that
it might do on the first time remove
this label prior to use
we're fine hi i'm katie and i'm a tasty
producer today we're going to be testing
and reviewing the grilled cheese
sandwich toaster by nostalgia we're
gonna try to figure out if the product
works if the food it makes tastes good
and if it's worth buying so let's get to
it here we go we've got the grilled
cheese sandwich toaster it makes you
feel nostalgic i guess i can see that
it's kind of going for like a 60 70s
vibe with this groovy grilled cheese
toaster writing we've got a nice crusty
little brown top so we're hoping we get
that nice toast as well and then there's
like these little baskets that get
dropped into the toaster let's see what
we got here
well you are definitely making a
statement in your kitchen
if you are excited about grilled cheese
sandwiches you need this maybe it's
heavy but not as heavy as you would hope
a toaster would be definitely don't drop
it i feel like it would crack but we've
got a dial
here for i think our different levels of
how long we want it to go melt zone like
what melt zone you want to go into and
then we've got some like little
sandwichy baskets here there's a lot
going on this is a lot of machinery but
you could be
it's got a retro vibe but i don't think
this was like a retro object i don't
think people had
this grilled cheese toaster in the past
i also discovered there's a little uh
tray that will catch
like melting cheese that's coming down
so that's pretty cool all right let's
make some grilled cheese
i've got cheddar cheese and i've got
some american cheese we're gonna make
two different sandwiches we're gonna see
what melts better this all looks pretty
intuitive but i'm gonna check the
instructions in case there's any safety
tips we need to know about it says to
plug it in we've done that it says to
butter the outside of two pieces of
bread which i'm absolutely gonna do
we're gonna go really classic today
let's preheat the toaster by pressing
down on the control lever which i think
is this guy so i'm gonna press him down
press preheat so this is going to heat
up and then it's going to pop them back
up when it's ready which i think is nice
because the metal is going to be nice
and hot maybe kind of like sear it a
little bit while that's happening i got
to quickly make some sandwiches probably
should have made the sandwiches actually
let me cancel this i'm going to make the
sandwiches first i'm using sourdough
bread because i just think it has such a
lovely flavor and then i'm gonna get my
other one flip this over we want the
butter to be on the outsides we're gonna
do just some normal cheddar here it says
not to stuff it too thick so i'm just
gonna do two pieces of cheese we'll prep
two more pieces with some butter i have
not had american cheese
since i was a kid do you just rip this
this is definitely gonna melt well i
think i'm gonna do three pieces
since it's so thin grilled cheese is
something that my mom always made kind
of what i was having like a down day or
something she was like i know it'll
cheer you up a grilled cheese now it is
time to preheat this guy
this didn't warn us on the outside that
it could smoke the first time
you use it
so we're not going to be alarmed by that
and we are preheated insert
your sandwich into the toasting basket
then place the toasting basket into the
toasting slot and i insert
my sandwich
and then
i set that
hold on let me just adjust is that gonna
work better
okay
not yet no
doing two sandwiches is a little tricky
also my bread just might be too
thick
i can't imagine you stuffing this with a
lot more
stuff okay the tops are not
in
i hope that's okay did i do that right
we're going down okay whatever now we
have to pick the melt zone i like mine
to be like a little bit on the darker
side i'm gonna go five it is smoking
which it did warn us that it might do on
the first time this will stop and does
not indicate a a defect or hazard remove
this label prior to use
read all the instructions everyone
we're fine this sandwich cannot cook on
a different uh melt zone than this
sandwich they've got they're both in the
same melt zone there's no dual climate
control on this now this is when it pops
up you need to let it sit for 30 seconds
before removing from the toaster this
will allow the cheese to fully melt
adjust the toasting dial to within the
melt zone levels four to six there is a
seventh zone on this but actually the
line also stops at six
why did they put a seven ah
stone okay it says it's ready
i'm gonna pop them up these guys look
like they could use a little more time
it says i can put it back down i'm gonna
go to like a two the forbidden level
seven do you think they just forgot that
they put a level seven on here as a
design flaw maybe or maybe that's a
retro thing
okay this back one is starting to look a
little burnt like the edges here are
starting to look a little too brown i'm
gonna let it sit for
30 seconds which it said this will allow
them to fully melt
all right let's take these groovy
sandwiches out of their toaster and see
how good they are
okay i'm lifting this guy up
okay um he's looking nice and toasty
kind of feels like a panini
um we've got some cheese that melted on
the bottom of that we've got our second
sandwich here
and he's looking like a little bit more
almost
whoa okay
that's a lot of cheese guys well at
least the cheese definitely melted
we definitely don't get an even toast
like this guy
toasted here but we're kind of missing
the whole area there this is almost
going too far and then we've totally
missed so not quite even but they're
nice
and crisp i'm gonna cut diagonally
because that's how my mom does it take a
look okay
this is our cheddar
and it's nice and melted and this is our
american cheese that's what i think that
they were using on the cover cause like
look how oozy which is a nice it's a
softer cheese which is also why it's
melting better okay plate them
let me do the old stackaroo
okay and i'm excited to give these a try
i'm gonna try the american cheese first
that tastes like my childhood that was
good next one here we go the cheddar
both were very crunchy very toasty the
american cheese sandwich i will give an
a minus because it's just classic and
for the cheddar cheese i'm going to give
it a b plus just because the cheese
didn't melt as much it didn't taste as
ooey gooey overall this made pretty good
grilled cheese sandwiches they were nice
and toasty though this is going to be
very hard to clean out because there is
cheese on the inside of this which
you're going to have to get into somehow
oh why don't we check what's going on
also with the cheese drip tray it really
only caught one little trip but it
caught a lot of toast so make sure you
clean that out because i could imagine
after a time like build up that like
some of these pieces could burn overall
i think this is gonna be really hard to
clean and you can't again submerge this
under water because it's like an
electrical device i'm not sure what it's
doing better than a pan because on a pan
when you make a grilled cheese you get a
much more even like toast and this one
was kind of spotty this was 20 i don't
know if you need to spend 20 maybe make
a grilled cheese on a pan and go see a
movie instead i don't know i don't think
it's worth the money this might be a fun
gift for someone who is obsessed with
grilled cheese but overall for everyday
use this is gonna be a thumbs down for
me okay that's it for the grilled cheese
toaster let us know in the comments what
else you want us to test out and review
and we'll see you guys next time thanks
for watching
oh yes
[Music]
you